my part of the ship is in Antwerp
Belgium and let me tell you
this place
uh we just happen to be staying in an
area that is highly decorated with
pickpockets okay
my head has been on a swivel for the
last 20 minutes have you got have you
like has anyone tried anything
you just a lot of a lot of dudes roaming
around and grabbing your ass back yeah
oh I'm sorry about that too nice ass man
mind if I get a handful you're like
please be my guests sorry about that too
don't you worry okay don't you worry
can't wait but a lot of dudes in packs
of fours with
um
hands
hands looking Shifty speaking of ass
grabs I'll just in Glasgow and after the
show some people are hanging outside the
Sprinter and I said what's up and this
dude fully grabbed my ass as a bit no
way really yeah yeah
I was like whoa I got groped
and he said oh he's like sorry sorry and
then he was really wasted and then he
talked to me about some other things and
then he left
it talks like just change the subject
yeah like he just you know he's just
being a lad it was just a you know
yeah cheeky lad grab
I kind of want to I probably would have
been pissed
[Laughter]
yeah from my English people yeah no I
was pissed but for all my English people
you're all familiar with Ladbroke um
that was a lad grope
um yeah no I was I was pretty like what
the [__] man where did where
do you get off thinking that look what
you can't touch yeah exactly you know
you could you could you could lay your
eyes on these tasty cakes but so help
you God that you reached over the
[__] counter did he did he compliment
you at all
um yeah no he gripped it boy oh boy now
that's a handful yeah God damn
you're my yeah you're you're the
thickest comedian on Twitter
um
now he took a grip and he's like huh is
this what in and out feels like
because these are some buns right here
you bet you could fit Five Guys in these
buns oh yeah
yeah no it was it was definitely weird
yeah I don't know how to feel kind of
sucks
yeah yeah I got my ass grabbed yeah well
to be fair
um his girl she and I'm sorry I'm just
taking off with conversation here but
it's just at the front of my mind that's
fine go go ahead
um his lady
for the photo
she jokingly
you know because I said something about
my height relative to hers because she's
a bit taller than me and
she said short king I said yep and then
she goes oh wait and then she wraps her
arms around my midsection and then just
like dropped down like squat so her head
is by my waist it was an innocent [__]
she was trying to be funny
but then Tom was like hey yo hey let's
chill and then she realized what she was
doing and then she stood right back up
and you turn around and her boyfriend is
down by your ass oh yeah yeah he was
gripping with both hands no his dad yeah
beat his face down here yeah yeah yeah
he he gripped me up that so she did that
and then he gripped me up and then
this young lady comes up and we take a
photo and then she says I just have to
let you know that I was introduced to
you by a guy who used to make me suck
his nipples while jacking him off
hahaha
that's that's [__] that's great
that's unique yeah dare I say hard ass
intro hey yeah seriously yeah
yeah that's what um yeah it was I it was
really weird it was funny I can't I have
zero there's zero sexual anything coming
from my nipples
[Laughter]
I have no sensitivity there that is in
any way related to anything sexual at
all hold up hold up really so you're
saying you're saying you could get your
nipple uh absolutely sucked and sucked
off
and uh
what why are you like someone it would
feel like someone's sucking on my elbow
is that from diving you just get like
like damage your nipples maybe from
running I've just shaved every nerve oh
yeah
it just counts there
yeah you've got foreskin on your nipples
you got to pull them back to get to the
good part you're telling me like if you
like if a girl like rubbed your nipples
or I mean I guess your wife
like touched your nipples that would
like turn you on like you'd be like uh
you actually no no you're you're right
you're right I don't think I have much I
don't have much feeling there either
nice dude I do this for the whole time
not even get hard a little bit
somebody clipped that somebody clipped
that
that's a good clip right there man like
you know as the guy in that scenario you
wouldn't you assume that he would want
the mouth to be on the penis
why I guess not and man some some guys
they they like the nipple play
I don't understand they're they're about
it well I think what was weird and I I
don't want to be misremembering here but
I think she said that
she would do this while they
watched my content
but that doesn't sound right okay
because you're jacking me off yeah that
doesn't sound right maybe the maybe the
video was like a precursor like come
over let's hang out let's watch these
videos you know and then it then it just
happens to be there in the background
but
I don't think he's going like yo
put on my put on put on that mustache
man you know step one
skinny penis vine on on repeat yeah yeah
dude set your YouTube on replay anyway
what is it is it Monday over there yeah
[__] you
I'm asking
well it is a Globetrotter now just yeah
you know man I'm just around I don't
know time zones anymore man it's like
I'm hopping from one hemisphere to the
next and you get kind of you know lose
track of what of normal life or
yeah a lot of people think the world is
this like one big place but like you
know once you just like learn to step
out of your comfort zone
that's all you have to do is just step
you know what like for me I do
you know like I thought like forever
like you know Orange County was it you
know and then I stepped out of my
comfort zone and
you know now I got a palace in Bali and
um you know that's why I always
recommend people
to people travel you know get out there
for two years at least
at a minimum
just take three years off man like
everyone should take three years off
uh that's what I tell people everyone
and it's weird that people choose not to
just yeah
take three years off life is a choice
man I agree like life is definitely a
choice and and you can you can make a
choice you can either choose to work for
three years for a job that you don't
care about or go to Bali no and surf and
do yoga
and make that your life like which one
seems like better work
oh Bala yoga hanging out with monkeys
smoothie bowls
uh or whichever is better
heavier
Yeah man so you know what day is it
[Laughter]
Monday
it is Monday all right